I think you all brought some
friends here too with you.
Can we Say hello to
your little friends?
Bring that gold man with us.
Spoiler alert, this
all worked out.
I'm excited to be with you all
this morning, Academy Gold.
We got the production track,
we got Gold Extension,
we got the alumni
of Academy Gold,
and our partner company interns.
So welcome to you all.
Excited to have you here and for
this bright light of sunshine
that we're going to enjoy
today, the making of Hair Love.
And let me give you
a brief introduction,
and then we're going to
have the special treat that
gets it all going.
First, we'll be joined
by Matthew A. Cherry, who
is director, writer, producer
of this wonderful Academy
award-winning project,
and joining Matthew
will be Karen Toliver, who's
a producer on the film,
but also an EDP creative
at Sony Pictures Animation.
So with that, we're going to
actually see the short again.
I think some of you
have seen it already
in advance of the
ceremony last year
or this year, a lifetime ago.
But let's watch the
short, and then we'll
dive into the making of it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Meow.
- [YAWNING]
- [HUMMING]
Just took a little bit of
work and a whole lot of love.
- Are you ready to do this?
All right.
Here we go.
See, now wasn't that easy?
- [CROWD CHEERING]
Aw!
- [SIGHING]
- See?
Now, wasn't that easy?
All it takes is some
confidence and a willingness
to get started.
And even though I'm not there,
I'll guide you through this.
I want to thank my very special
assistant, my daughter, Zuri,
for helping me with
today's blog like always.
And remember, the road
ahead might look rough,
but you can make the journey
with a little bit of work
and a whole lot of love.
Are you ready to do this?
All right, here we go.
First, you want to moisturize
these beautiful, thick curls
with a leave-in
conditioner, which will also
help detangle the kinks.
Now, part all right
your hair into sections,
and clip it away.
You're doing an amazing job.
Yay!
You did it!
That was so much fun.
I knew you could do it.
- (SINGING) Right.
Right.
It will be all right because
it's already all right.
Right.
It'll be all right, because
it's already all right.
Yeah.
Happy days.
Whoa.
That's right.
When you do right, 10
feet tall and a mile high.
Happy days.
Whoa.
That's right.
When you live right.
Finally got a piece of the pie.
[END PLAYBACK]
So thank you all,
again, for being here,
and please join me in welcoming
Matthew Cherry and Karen
Toliver.
Hey, guys.
How are you doing?
There you are.
Hello.
Hey, Brickson.
Thanks for having us.
Welcome.
I think you all brought some
friends here too with you.
Can we Say hello to
your little friends?
Bring that gold man with us.
Spoiler alert, this
all worked out.
So let's talk about the
journey from beginning
to those new roommates
that you all have.
So let's start out.
We're talking about the
inspiration for the story.
I'd love to begin
with you, Matthew.
Just give us a sense of where
this idea came from and how
was it brought to life
at the very early stages?
Ah, man, you know, this journey
started about three years ago,
actually, four years ago.
I'll take it back to
the earliest point.
I remember watching the
Oscars the year of 2016
and trying to make a habit
of watching it every year.
And for this year,
in particular,
I don't know why I was
paying extra attention
to all the categories, not
just director, best picture,
and everything else, watching
documentary short and sound
editing and sound mixing.
And I came across the
animated short category,
and I've had this idea
already in my head.
And I remember after watching,
I forget who won that year,
watching them win, getting
the same statue that director
and best picture got.
And I remember calling my
manager, Monica Young, who
was a producer on the
project too and being like,
Monica, you know what, I
was like, I got an idea
for an animated short film.
And I literally showed her this.
I was like, and if
we do this right,
I think we could mess
around and win an Oscar.
And she didn't laugh at
me because we had never
done an animated project before,
and she was very encouraging.
She was like, all right,
let's try to figure it out.
And I remember in
2016, I put a tweet
out saying that I had
an Oscar-worthy animated
short film idea.
I had come across
this image of--
it was a 3D image
from this artist
in Brazil named Julian
Santiago, and it
was an Afro-Latino father.
He was sitting at his
workstation trying to draw,
and his daughter was sitting
on his lap looking up at him
and just kind of an initial
inspiration in terms of imagery
for the film.
And I put the tweet
out, trying to see
if I can get some 3D
artists to holler at me,
and it kind of fell on
deaf ears a little bit,
for whatever reason.
And I kind of
forgot out about it
and ended up doing a movie
that I shot on iPhones called
9 Rides that was shot
in the course of a week
around the week of
Thanksgiving 2016,
and then we ended up getting
into South by Southwest.
And that project always kind
of was in the back of my mind,
and I was trying
to figure it out,
and I came across this
artist, Vashti Harrison, who
a friend of mine, a
filmmaker named Nisla Muman,
had posted a picture that she
drew of her for a birthday
around the summer of 2017.
And I had never seen somebody
draw Black hair like this.
It was very accurate.
Nisla has incredible braids
and natural hairstyles.
And I reached out to Vashti
and I was like, look,
I've been thinking
about this project
I can't get out of my mind.
I'm thinking about doing
an animated short film,
and I would love to
see if you would be
down to do some artwork for us.
And she was down, had
talked to Monica about it.
We did the Kickstarter campaign,
and the rest was history.
And if you move forward
on the next slide,
a lot of amazing things
happened from it.
We offered different
gifts like a picture book,
which ended up becoming a
New York Times best seller.
We offered different gifts
like pens and T-shirts
and all kinds of things.
And if you go to
the next slide, we
ended up just having our
initial goal was $75,000,
and we ended up setting this
record of almost $300,000
that we raised in the
course of 30 days.
And till this day, it's still
the highest grossing short film
Kickstarter in the
history of the platform.
And we just had so many great
people back the project,
people like Jordan
Peele and Chris Rock
and Chance the Rapper, Chelsea
Clinton, Dwyane Wade, Gabrielle
Union, so many great people.
And it was just crazy
because I remember
we had a list of all
the different press
outlets that we wanted to
cover the Kickstarter campaign.
And oftentimes, when
you're doing a Kickstarter,
it's all pretty
much a pipe dream
in terms of, hopefully, these
people will respond to you.
And within the first
week of the project,
every single outlet that
we had on our target
have reached out to us
before we even had a chance
to reach out to them.
So it was just magic
on this project
ever since the beginning.
And for us, I think it was the
combination of being inspired
by a lot of these viral videos
of the dads that were doing
their daughter's
hair, and we knew
that we could capture
that same magic
that we would be successful
in terms of raising the money.
And I just think, also, we
dropped this Kickstarter
at a time where it was right
before this whole inclusion
and diversity push that
has happened recently
in the world of animation.
This is before Moana came out.
This is before Coco.
This is before Into
the Spider-Verse.
And people were
really just clamoring
to see themselves
represented in this medium
that Karen said
in their speeches
the first form of filmmaking
that were exposed to.
And when you don't see yourself,
especially when you're young,
it really does a number
on your self-confidence.
And I just think it was one
of those situations where
we were kind of right
place, right time.
Like Matthew said, I mean, when
I became aware of the project,
it was before all of this
things, before Moana and Coco,
and those things.
And I had been working in
animation as an executive
first at Disney Pictures, then
I was at Fox for 10 years.
I worked on the Ice Age
franchise, I worked on Rio,
and then I was actually
just at the end of Fox
and coming to Sony when
I knew Monica Young, who
was one of the producers and
Matthew's manager, socially.
But we didn't even know,
really, what each other did.
So all this lead up,
as Matthew got the idea
and did the
Kickstarter, and they
were looking for
someone to help them
through the animation process.
And I was lucky enough
that I was one of the few.
Monica asked if I could
help these guys produce it.
And having never
in my career been
able to work on a project
about Black people
that's so personal,
there's no way to say no.
You just know how
important it is.
You know how personal it would
be and how fun it would be.
But I had huge
caveats because I was
like I'd never, ever worked
on anything like this
on this level.
The movies that I work on are
big, million-dollar movies,
and there's a whole
infrastructure
of how these movies get made and
technical people and all that.
And my expertise is in
the front end of story
and overseeing the
story and really
kind of helping put
the pieces together
and putting the team together.
So when asked, and again, they
raised an incredible amount
of money on Kickstarter,
but it was still
small to get something to the
caliber that Matthew wanted.
My biggest caveat
was like, just know
I have absolutely no
idea how to do this.
I know what your goal is.
I know what your intent-- and
his intent was everything.
It was really what led us
all through every stage
of the process because we
knew he wanted that gold.
We wanted that gold.
We were going to figure
it out, but really
doing it at a small
scale with those means
are more difficult
than you would think.
And like the image
that's here, we
knew that we were
going to be telling
a story about a black
family in a short,
and that had never
really been done.
And so the goal in holding
the responsibility of that
was really high on our
minds, because we knew
that they had to be beautiful.
We knew we had to look great.
In the first couple
of choices, I
think if you go
to the next slide,
we knew we were
dealing with hair.
And again, Vashti's
image was so beautiful
that we had to make a choice
pretty early on whether we
were going to do CG or 2D.
And we knew that it was going to
be very difficult on the budget
that we had to really do the
loving care that we needed
for this family and
represent hair and make it
really a personality and retain
the beauty of Vashti's design.
So pretty quickly on, we
knew that 2D was really
going to be the way to go.
And we just had
to figure out who
was going to be able to
do it because it just
had to look great.
Let's talk about the
character design.
So we're getting into the
deep heart of animation
now, so everybody
hold on to your hats.
Let's talk about
these characters
and the process of bringing
them to life for the short.
Yeah, let me set the stage,
and then I'll pass it to Karen.
So when we did our initial
Kickstarter campaign,
the dad actually
looked way different
than he looks in
our final design.
He was a little bigger.
We described him
as a gentle giant.
He had locks, but
he looked like he
may have been in his mid 40s.
I'll say he looked a little
"safer," quote, unquote.
And when Karen came on board,
I think one of the best ideas
that she had was the idea
of just really pushing
the imagery of how
we perceive Steven.
It really felt like
an opportunity for us
to normalize young Black
fathers because that's
a very specific segment
of mainstream media, where
young Black men
are often vilified,
and you don't really see them
in these more softer, nurturing
roles.
And studies have shown
that Black men are
amongst the biggest
and most involved
when it comes to
their kids' lives,
whether they're with
the mother or not.
And that was one of
Karen's biggest things
I felt like she
brought to the project
because just, really, I
think for a lot of people,
it just made it even more
relatable and grounded
and just really represents what
the modern family looks like.
It was not families being
40 plus and the house
and the white picket fence.
It's a little less linear.
And so definitely, I just wanted
to give major props to Karen
for bringing that idea because
I think that was the thing that
really opened it up.
So yeah, the challenge
with animation
is every level of
detail just makes
it more difficult to
animate, and so we
had the challenge of taking
Vashti's drawings, which
is so beautiful and very
delicate and detailed
in the book.
And as Matthew said, everything
about this process with Hair
Love was unconventional.
So that was another
thing I learned.
Don't worry about
what you've been told.
Usually, you either get a
book and then you make a short
or maybe you make--
I guess people don't even make
a short and then make a book.
So the fact that this was
going on at the same time
is highly unusual
because usually, one
would drive the other.
So we knew that we
wanted Vashti's designs
to be really important,
but these designs,
from a technical standpoint,
felt too detailed
to really allow the animators
to do their thing, particularly
with the budget that we had.
So part of our journey
was to figure out
how to make sure that you could
identify Zuri as the book went
along and people were going to
get to know her in the book,
but make sure that she
was representative enough
in the short so that she
felt like the same character.
But at the same time,
we were using all sorts
of ideas of how graphic we
wanted the character to be
in the short and had to figure
out how to translate that.
So that was really
important, and it
was a lot of technical things
that we had to figure out
to make that work.
But again, our team was
amazing, and a lot of it
was about hair and the
software that we were using.
So there's a process
called Harmony,
and that's a 2D
software, but we had
to figure out how to
translate in this,
and we'll talk about
that a little bit.
And so this is
the first designs,
and then we can
keep going forward,
and you can see more of how
she evolved to the process.
And Vashti did, again,
these expression sheets,
and we fell in love,
and that's what
helped to get the money
for the Kickstarter
because people felt like
they already knew this girl.
So we had to really protect
Zuri through the process
so that we didn't lose her.
And if you go to the next one.
Then we started looking at
how to simplify that design
and use other references.
So here's a series
of picture books
that had a much more graphic
look and a simplified look.
So the exercise was how much
could you scale down images
and still get the connectivity.
So we love the beauty and
the elegance and simplicity
of this book, Island Born,
and that was a big inspiration
as we moved forward.
There was Ezra Keats, Snowy Day.
There's a lot of
just beautiful stuff,
and then Tiffany Ford
was a character designer
that we fell in love
with and actually, wanted
to work with on the short.
But we really were
exploring the use of color
and how that really translated
into the characters.
And then there's many
others that finally led us
to the design you see with
Zuri, I think, in the next,
and this is what we landed on.
So that was the journey of the
book, the illustrated version
of Zuri to the one that
we found in animation.
The other key, and we'll
talk about this in a minute,
but the contrast between how we
wanted the characters to look,
which, again, had more
detail, but we really
wanted to keep an
artistic appeal to each
of the frames of the thing
so it was really as beautiful
and painterly as possible.
So you'll notice when we
get to the backgrounds,
they're not as detailed.
They're much more
watercolor and sort
of expression kind of vibe,
more than the characters.
Yeah, and as you can
see, this is probably
the first iteration of Zuri.
And while, obviously,
she retains
some of the charm from Vashti's
initial drawing, for me,
I was like, we can always
do a little bit better.
And you can see how when
Bruce Smith came on board
and was able to really get
in there and into the details
and how small things like
slightly tweaking the profile,
adjusting the ear
location, having the belly
protrude a little bit, smaller
feet, so many small details
that an artist with as
much experience as Bruce,
he just totally
brings to the table.
It just makes her
so much more cuter
and have so much more appeal.
And if you go to the
next slide, these
are also some different
things that we
did to try to make her
as cute as possible,
and this ended up
being our final design.
And a lot of it was
just a lot of tweaking,
making sure that her skin
color was a certain way, making
sure the hair texture looked a
very certain way because as you
guys know in mainstream media,
so often, certain images are
pushed to the forefront,
especially when it comes
to Black women.
And for us, it
was very important
that her hair was as
kinky as we could make it.
She was brown, more
browner skin tone,
things like making
the mom a little
darker than her and the father.
Just small things that
I think, on the surface,
may not seem like a
big deal, but were
things that once the
short film was released,
they were things
that we constantly
were getting comments on
about things that they loved,
especially the hair texture.
These are some of the early
hairstyle designs that we did.
As you know, Black women,
their hair is a super power,
and you can style it
in many different ways,
and we just wanted to see what
our different hairstyles would
look on Zuri's cute face.
So these were some
of the hairstyles
that we did, and you
go to the next one.
And of course, in
animation, I would just
say that every time
you change a hairstyle,
you're changing the rig,
you're doing a lot to it.
So this is where six point
shows how they were actually
able to do the hair in sections
to really kind of give it
the volume that it wanted.
I think if you hit Play,
it should turn around.
You can see a little bit
of what that looks like.
Yeah.
And so this was our model that
we used in the short film.
As you can see, the hair
is in different sections.
And if you go to the next
one, these are literally just
like a whole sheet of just
all the different hairstyles
that we had on
mom's YouTube page.
It's really trying to represent
the full breadth of Black hair,
and the blog was a really great
opportunity to showcase that.
Let's go forward, a slide.
I think we're going to
move into look development.
Karen, you talked
about this a bit
before, if we go a little bit
further in terms of the palette
and the painterly
vision of the film.
So give us a bit more
and sort of sharpen
this view and the less
sharp view of the scenery.
Sure.
Yeah.
Again, we really
had high intentions
about how beautiful we
wanted this to look,
and we had reference in shorts
like there was a short called
Dam Keeper that was
very inspirational to us
because it did have a beautiful
watercolor kind of aesthetic.
And so again, knowing that we
had a path with the character
designs because of
the book and Vashti,
we thought the backgrounds were
really where we could go crazy.
And so the first thing we do--
and again, I'm not an artist.
We really leaned on Stacey
Newton and Everett Downing
to really help us dig deep
on this and pull reference.
And the first go to for any
animator is Maurice Noble, who
did a bunch of the Looney Tunes,
and there's just something
really gorgeous about his work.
And it's very simple.
You've got the broad colors
and the simple pencil lines.
And we really were
inspired by that look.
If you go forward, you
can see the coloring
and just so much that even
without any characters
in there, the background
themselves stood apart,
and that was really
the inspiration.
We wanted to use color
in a really bold way.
We just found these
really gorgeous.
And then there was another
artist, Walter Peregoy,
who worked One Hundred
and One Dalmatians,
so this was incredible,
again, just very stylized,
but really got the idea across.
You don't want the background
to really stand out too much.
You really want to support
the foreground, of course,
but we thought that these
designs were just amazing.
And there was one
other, Helen Lundberg,
who's a surrealist painter
they introduced us to.
So all of this
was the ammunition
to put just what this
inspiration for how
we wanted these to look.
And so that was the
question is, can you really
reduce this to color and shape?
How much can we get away with.
And this image that you'll
see is Zuri in the background.
I think our art designer,
Maria Yee, who's amazing
and when she really
kind of synthesized
this look in the bathroom,
we realized this was it.
This really gave us the
look that we wanted.
We loved how rich and
beautiful the background was.
We liked how it let Zuri popped
in the front, and we were like,
OK, every shot of
this short should
feel like a painting like this,
and if we can get that across,
I think we're in good shape.
And so it was really about broad
brush work and just really kind
of getting that painterly look.
And so that's really
the first thing we did.
And then we went on to the
other locations you'll see.
And the funny thing,
again, in terms
of the amount of work
we did is that there's
one location in here you never
see in the short, the living
room on the bottom right,
which was sad because it
was one of our favorite.
And as we were designing, we're
like we're on World Market
picking furniture
and really kind
of really giving love to this.
And again, Matt, you
can speak to this,
but it was, again,
very grounded.
We know where they live.
We know what kind of building
it was, and all of that
was really important.
Yeah, we spoke about this family
being from Chicago, very much
not quite middle class,
but working their way up,
which is so much the experience
of a lot of young 20-year-olds
that are either
fresh out of college
or are going into
their late 20s.
And we wanted the
apartment and brownstone
that they lived in to
really reflect that.
And so when we go
to the next slide,
you'll see an early model
of the bathroom, which
we knew was going to play such
a big part of the short film.
Because Zuri was going to be
in there doing her hair styles
and also, would be
the location when
Dad stepped up
and was able to do
her hairstyle the correct way.
And so this early design
was done in sketch up,
and then you see the final
design, how beautiful that is.
I mean, every time
I see this, I'm
just like that, literally,
looks like the bathroom
that I grew up in in Chicago,
with old-school radiator
and the tiles and the brick
and even the little drawing
above the toilet, which
just adds so much charm.
And so and a lot of the
stuff really evolved as well
if you go to the next one.
And you'll see this is an early
version and iteration of we
thought Zuri's bedroom
would look like.
As you can see, there's
a lot of pink around.
And one thing that
we talked about
is just like when we
were working on this,
it's 2017, 2018, 2019,
and we don't necessarily
have to lean into the
stereotypical color palette
that young girls are into.
We can kind of push it and
make it a little bit more
non-binary.
So if you go to
the next slide, you
can see that we ended up going
with the blue wall instead
of all pink everything,
kind of having more pink
and purple accents and really,
coming with the brown hardwood
floors to give it
a lot of charm.
And then the last
one is the hospital.
And when we got this
design, we were just
I don't think we had any notes.
It just looked so good.
He almost forgot we
needed the hospital.
That I remember.
It was like, wait.
We forgot to design
the hospital.
I guess we need to do that.
Yeah.
Again, just it's so beautiful,
and a majority of this
was just more like location.
Like, OK, she's going
to be at the window.
All right, we need to move the
TV and everything else and just
making sure this
looked authentic
and again, Maria did
an incredible job.
It's incredible.
I'd love to talk about how
you developed the story.
You have 6 and 1/2 minutes
to tell these three people's
lives plus the cat.
And let's talk a bit
about that journey.
I'd worked a lot of
music videos and a lot
of short-form filmmaking.
And I always loved trying
to figure out twist endings
and things that will shock
the system a little bit,
but are also additive
to the narrative.
And for me, the
idea of them going
through this whole journey
of trying to do her hair,
but then you see the reason.
And the reason is because Mom
has lost confidence in herself
and thinking that
she's maybe not
as beautiful as she once was
because she's lost her hair.
And the idea that Zuri
was able to get her dad
to do her hair in a
style that her mom used
to do, it's so
encompassing and just
adds on a nice little
dimension and also showcases
that they're a nuclear family
and kind of teasing the idea
that maybe he's a single dad.
What happened to the mom?
You kind of introduce all these
questions in the beginning,
and now, I think people
really appreciated the fact
that Mom was alive at the end.
And then also, it went
even up until the credits,
the different end
credits that we
had that showed mom's hair
growing back during each slide.
Just things like that
that just showcase OK,
not only is she going home,
but now she's getting better,
and they're going to
actually have a happy ending.
So yeah, we can get into
a little bit of the story
development.
Go to the next slide.
So in animation, and this is
my first experience with this,
I mean, so much of it is just
like redoing and watching
amongst a collective
group of people,
and all right, let's
all give notes on it.
What's working,
what isn't, and just
constantly, you're refining and
making sure that it's right.
And I love that compared to
live action filmmaking, which
I have a lot of experience in.
And a lot of times being a
filmmaker is very isolating,
and you're feeling like
a lot of the decisions
are on your shoulders and
it kind of lives and dies
with the director.
But the thing I
love about animation
is you may not have the
best idea, and that's OK.
You can take from whoever,
and if it makes sense,
you add it to the final project,
and it's very collaborative.
And so this was an original
ending that we had conceived.
This is probably one of
the earlier beginnings
of the short film that we had.
And go ahead and play it,
and I'll explain to you
why we changed it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
All right.
So ignore the creepy
guy in the background.
He came with the
design of the set.
So this version of
the beginning was
like we were trying to get
a lot of information across.
We knew that the short film
wasn't going to have words,
so we were going to have
to really show a lot.
And the idea of this
was, Dad is exhausted.
He's been on his own for
a couple of weeks, trying
to take care of
Zuri and also, he's
trying to work on his
music because he's
a music producer and also,
really wanting to showcase
how independent Zuri is.
She's able to make breakfast.
She's able to pick
up after herself.
And she's trying
to sneak by her dad
to grab his iPad so she can
get into these hair designs.
And the thing that we
notice is like, OK,
Dad just looks like
a horrible parent.
He looks lazy.
He looks like he's
just knocked out.
We're not really able to
set up the reason why.
And so we just we
agreed that Dad
needed to be more
active in order to get
that same information across.
And then if you go
to the next one,
we could show you the
2.0 version of that,
trying to show Dad being
a little bit more active.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [SNIFFING]
[END PLAYBACK]
So this version of it shows
Dad being way more active.
It definitely gets across the
fact that he's overwhelmed.
He's trying to pick
up after himself.
Food is burning on the stove.
He's tripping over stuff.
And the thing that we
found is that, obviously,
with a short film, you want to
keep it as tight as possible,
and we felt that there was a
way to essentially introduce him
later in the story
just to kind of set up
Zuri's journey of being
very much an active kid,
being confident in herself,
being able to get herself ready
and to get into the bathroom.
And we decided that we could
bring in Dad a little later
in the story and introduce
him in that moment
that you saw in the final short
film, where he's walking across
with the laundry
basket and drops it
and is immediately dropped
into the story in that way.
And so the next clip that
you'll see that we ended up
cutting out, which is the
last bit that we'll show you
in terms of some of the early
story stuff that didn't make it
was this idea of really
trying to set up Zuri.
We realized that we wanted
Zuri to be very active.
One of the biggest
questions with animation
is, why are we animating it?
This is live action.
You need to add things in
there that really justifies
the use of the
medium, and one thing
that we realized that we wanted
was these fantasy sequences.
And the initial idea was Zuri
having a big imagination, which
she's swiping through
the hairstyles,
she imagines herself with
these different hairstyles
of which he may be doing in the
world with those hairstyles.
And so let's play it, and I'll
break it down a little more.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [CROWD APPLAUSE]
- [SCREAMING]
- (SINGING)
[END PLAYBACK]
Right.
And so obviously, those
scenes are very cute.
The big thing for us though
that ended up happening
was totally the fact that we
were living in Zuri's fantasies
for as long as we were felt like
they were stepping on the more
serious ending of the short
film, where we were going
to be dealing with,
obviously, Mom being sick,
and we didn't really want
to step on that as much.
And we came to the decision
that it would be best
to quickly get through
Zuri trying to figure out
the different hairstyles and
also, make the cat a little bit
more active in her
decision making.
And then in terms of
the fantasies, actually
giving that to dad
and having that
be a way that he can
express like his fears
in terms of this daunting task
of trying to do his daughter's
hair and that not stepping
on the tone of the ending
as much as us living in
Zuri's fantasies for so long.
So those are some deleted
scenes from the short film
that exclusive group of
you have been able to see.
And Karen will bring you through
some of the animation process.
Yeah, and that's really
the secret sauce.
If there's one thing that is
the reason why I love animation
so much is that ability to just
write and rewrite and learn
by seeing it up
many, many times.
I think that when we're
really kicking hard on this,
it was probably a
year-long process,
but the first seven or I think
the first nine months were
really about just
rewriting these storyboards
and making sure
that they were right
and getting everybody's
notes to get it right.
Yeah, so then the next
stage is animation,
and this was really
important to us
and again, why we really
needed Bruce Smith to come in,
because we knew we really
wanted these characters to move
as beautifully as possible.
And none of us had
work in Harmony before.
We knew it mostly
from television shows,
and again, wanted to just
make it as fluid as possible.
So we were able to figure out
a process by which we could
get the best of both worlds.
So we wanted to search
for great 2D animators,
hand-drawn animators
that could really give us
the fluidity of what we wanted.
And then they could put it
into the system called Harmony.
And what Harmony
does is it builds
a rig or a model
for the characters,
and you're able to actually
take the 2D animation that you
do first and apply it to
the rig so the rig can
follow the movements
of the 2D animators.
So the first couple
I want to show you
is an amazing
animator, Mike Owens.
And you'll see how fluid and
cartoony you can make it,
and then we'll show
you what the final is.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So when you do 2D, you can see
the squash and stretch and just
sort of the personality
that can come out.
So we really loved what
Mike was bringing there.
And it allowed him to
really find the character
without working in the model,
and he didn't know that system.
So we were able to do that.
And then if you move to,
I believe the next one,
you can see what the
final looks like.
So you get some of that
performance in the storyboards,
but really, it came
to life in animation.
[END PLAYBACK]
That's really so
beautiful and so worthy
of the ambition
you all had for it
and just an incredible
piece of art.
So congratulations on that.
We're going to go to questions.
So everyone is going
to get teed up.
In the meantime, I'm
going to start off
with this question that's
more Academy Gold focus.
So many of our
students are really
thinking about
working on pitching
their ideas as a project
for the Gold program.
I'm curious as to when
you went in the room
to pitch this, in
your pitch sessions,
a few questions in that regard.
Who was involved in that first
pitch in terms of your team?
Who was in the room
from the other side?
And did you go through
the whole deck in the way
you did for us today, or
what did that look like?
So who, on your side,
who on their side,
what did you show them,
and what happened?
I love that you think
that we pitched this.
Kickstarter was our pitch.
We went straight to the people.
I think that's
something that I think
is so amazing about the world
today with social media.
If you build up your
following enough
or if you have enough people
that will support your vision,
or if you've proven that
you're the type of person that
will follow through on things,
you can take it to the internet
and crowdfund.
And sometimes,
strange things happen.
Sometimes you just never know.
You may be dropping a
project at the perfect time,
and the right person retweets
it, it now goes viral,
and now it's on studio's radars.
The thing for us is that I
knew for a fact that if I were
to went to Disney, Pixar, maybe
even Sony without having proven
anything had been like, hey, I
want to do a short film about
a Black dad who's doing
his daughter's hair,
I probably would have got
laughed out the room--
you know what I mean--
in a way.
And the reason I say that is
also because 9 times out of 10,
it's also about
the executives that
are on the other
side of the table
and people that are able to
relate to these experiences.
Sony is great in that they
have people like Karen that
are actually
decision makers that
are able to see
the humanity and I
think in stories that are a
little broader and a little bit
more inclusive.
That's not the case with
a lot of other studios.
And I think that in terms of
being a creative nowadays,
you just have to bet on
yourself and do the work
and be that a short film,
be that a presentation
or just trying to
raise the money
and kind of bringing the
attention and the momentum
to you.
That's what we did.
So I'll say Kickstarter
was our pitch pages
and having raised $300,000 and
going viral, that just gave us
so much more momentum to be
able to have conversations
with people like Kerry.
And just to jump in,
I mean, you're right.
Sony doesn't have
a shorts program,
so my involvement was,
as an outside producer,
doing it just on the
love of the project
until it started
to gain momentum
and we could actually
show what we were doing.
And then Sony got on board and
realized how important it was,
but Matthew is exactly right.
Going to the people
and the people
proving that there's a need
made my job much easier.
I couldn't have done
it without that.
The funny thing,
though, is we did,
as you know we're
doing a television show
version of this.
The thing about that
was the first time
I'd ever been on the other
side pitching to a network.
I'm like, wait a minute,
I'm on this side,
so that was the scary part.
But it didn't hurt having
an Academy win behind it.
Did you bring the
statue with you
and just put him on the table
and say, make this film.
That was the whole pitch.
That was the pitch.
How you like me now.
To be fair, they
knew it was valuable
before we won the
Oscar, so props to HBO
for really seeing that beauty.
Fantastic.
So our Academy Gold
folks are here with us,
and we're going to start
out with our questions.
Destiny, you're up first.
Hello.
Hi.
How are you?
Thank you for coming.
I wanted to ask one
question because my biggest
fear as a Black creator is
that my Black mind will have
to be compromised for coming
off socially or politically
correct.
So I wanted to know
as Black creators,
have you ever felt
through this process
that you have to
compromise yourself,
and how did you go about
that and stand your ground?
You know what's so interesting
is that I've always
been pretty outspoken,
especially when things aren't
right.
And for the most part,
it's worked for me.
I've yet to have a
seat here, and let
me show you your Twitter
timeline and kind of where
you're messing up.
But I think that's something
that everybody struggles with.
You want to be your
authentic self.
I do think that
there is pressure
to compromise yourself.
You may be trying to sell a
project and people are like,
well, you may maybe tone this
down or tone that down there
maybe we'll buy it
And I think you just
have to be in a position
where you're able to
make that decision.
Is it worth compromising
that, and if it isn't, know
that everything
isn't for everybody.
Maybe it's not destined for
you to work with that network.
There was a story that came
out about Michaela Coel, who
has that new series out
on HBO, I May Destroy You
and how she went to Netflix.
They were trying to get a
certain level of ownership,
and she said, no,
and she stepped away,
and she knew her value.
And then HBO stepped
in, and I don't
know exactly what
her terms were,
but they had to be more amenable
to what she wanted to do,
and she ended up
going with them.
And so I think it's just
situations like that.
The more that you
work in this industry,
I think the more
leverage you have
to get your unflinching,
unapologetic vision out there.
But when you are
starting out, you
may have to make
some compromises,
and I think it's just a matter
of are those things that you're
willing to live
with to get ahead
or to try to get those first
couple opportunities or not.
And don't feel like
you have to do that.
You can maybe do something to
take it straight to the people
and prove it that way.
And then you could be like
this is a proven entity
that people will support,
and take it or leave it.
Ashley, you're up next.
Hi, Matthew and Karen.
It's really great
to meet both of you.
This film means so
much to me, personally.
It captured so much
of my childhood
so perfectly on screen, so it
was really exciting to see.
And I want to thank you both
for showing us the concept
art and clips, and
I hope that they'll
make their way into the
actual series on HBO
too because they looked
really, really cool, especially
the superhero concept.
Oh, for sure.
And so for both of you, my
question is really general,
but if you have any advice
for aspiring Black writers
or producers who are trying
to enter the industry,
I'd love to hear it.
And from both of you, are
there any other genres
that you're interested
in exploring,
whether it's animation
or otherwise?
You want to go first, Karen?
I'm excited for you.
I remember just trying
to start your career.
It's scary, but it's
also really exciting
to just get going and just
all the possibilities.
And I just think that
when I talk to writers,
and you know this, that it has
to be something, obviously,
that you can't not
do because you're
going to face so many
obstacles that you just
have to be so passionate that
there's just nothing else
that you could imagine
yourself doing.
And just keep doing it, and
keep finding every opportunity
to kind of hone your craft.
And when you say genres,
I love that because I
think it's really exciting,
especially in animation
for us to explore genres
that have never really
been done before.
So even Spider-Verse, because it
was sort of a more all audience
and it felt like a more
live action Marvel movie
in good ways, but then it
was things you could do only
in animation, I
think the way we keep
pushing the envelope with all
genres are going to be great.
I'm excited about doing horror
in animation, all of that.
And I think that
more, as a writer,
that you are able to
try different things,
the more you're going
to hone your craft.
I can't watch horror,
really, but horror
takes you through every beat
and manipulates the audience
like no other, like comedy,
but in a different kind of way.
And so I think the more you
really just stretch yourself,
even if you've never
tried it before,
it'll all kind of distill
down to do something great.
And just back to, say for
for Matthew and Hair Love,
it's like there were so many
dimensions of what he wanted
to say and now that
I think that's why
this short was very rich.
So I think that when
you're thinking of writing,
it's like you can be
very layered in it.
The ones that don't work for
me are the ones that are like,
oh, it's just, it's a Black
astronaut, or it's like
or this that.
And it's like, OK,
yeah, but what?
We get you.
And we get that in
the first scene,
but how are you really
taking it into another level.
So just continue
to push yourself.
Yeah, I would agree.
I mean, with Hair Love, there
were so many levels to it.
It was like wanting to see more
representation and animation,
wanting young Black boys
and girls to see themselves
in animation, to see people
wearing their hair like that.
And then like, oh,
this is the character
that I can take
pride in, and I want
to have their poster
in my room, and I
want to wear their pin and
the backpack and all of that.
And then also, again,
even with our ending,
also wanting to bring
attention to hair loss
and how that's being rampant
in the Black community
and how alopecia and
other issues lead to that
and how that leads to a
lack of self-confidence.
So just really
trying to touch it
on a lot of different levels.
My advice would be writing
is writing and rewriting.
Writers write.
Directors direct.
Producers produce.
If you want to be a writer, you
have to constantly be writing,
and you have to have
more than one idea.
Because you may go and
pitch that one idea,
and it may be good enough
to get you on the radar,
but they may not want to
make it, but they're like,
what else you got?
And you want to be
able to-- while you
have people's
attention-- to come at it
from a lot of different angles.
And your first
couple of projects
may not be the thing that
gets your foot in the door.
I've been working in
Hollywood for 13 years.
I've done 30 plus music videos,
two live action short films,
two live action feature films,
10 episodes of TV directing.
And it took an animated
short film for me
to get my foot
fully in the door.
You know what I mean, in a
genre I never worked in before.
So you just gotta keep
at it, and I truly
believe that it takes
typically, five years or so
for a lot of people to really
get that first break and then
about 10 for them
to really make it
and be a force in the industry.
Think of it like that and
constantly be working,
and you'll be fine.
Thank you so much.
Sure.
Alejandra, you're up next.
Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much for your time.
This presentation
has been amazing.
My question is,
well, I would like
to know more about your
whole Kickstarter campaign.
How did it work?
What else do you do.
What do you think it helped
you achieve your goal,
and not even achieve it,
just surpassed it by far,
besides the amazing
idea, of course.
But I don't know.
Did you send emails?
Did you text people, your
incentives, and all that stuff.
I mean, I'll be very
transparent with it.
This was my third
Kickstarter campaign.
Typically, what I do, I've done
them for both my live action
features.
And typically, I would
launch a campaign
after I shot the project, and
then it'd be like, all right,
we're about to premiere
South by Southwest.
And then the week that
announcement goes out,
then I put the
campaign out to try
to raise money for finishing
funds and things like that.
This was different
because it was
like I had nothing to
show, say for some artwork.
I didn't have a trailer
to drop or anything.
Literally, it was just
a video, me being like,
this is the idea like a
car salesman or whatever.
And the reason why I feel
like this Kickstarter was
the most successful
on top of the idea
was, I put a lot more
effort into building up
my social media before
the campaign launched.
In 2016, I maybe had
25,000 followers.
And when Trump got, elected
I think for everybody,
for me, it made me be like, OK,
if you're not saying anything,
you're complicit.
So you've got to
be way more active.
You can't be scared
to be divisive.
You've got to call things
out when they're wrong.
And when Trump got
elected, I just
found myself way
more active in terms
of not even about film
stuff, but just like, OK,
the cages is a right.
Typical things that
you would think
are just like common knowledge,
but for whatever reason,
they end up being
divisive on social media,
and I found my following grow.
And I think a combination of
talking about political stuff,
talking about myself,
showing pictures of my dogs,
just like people getting
to know you as a person,
I was able to build it up
to around 100,000 followers
when the Kickstarter
campaign launched.
And typically, when you're
doing a campaign like this,
typically, maybe
2% or 3% of people
that follow you will actually
pull out their wallet and type
their credit card
information, you
know what I mean,
to support you.
And you've got to think
about it like that.
And the more people that
follow you in that way
and know you personally
and know your journey
are the more people
that will follow you.
And I think it was a
combination of that
plus people like
Lin Manuel Miranda,
maybe not donating, but
sharing their campaign
to their 3 million followers.
Chelsea Clinton,
Ben Stiller, I mean,
so many people that, and also
being intentional with that,
being like, OK, is you
donating $20 more valuable,
or are you retweeting this to
your millions of followers?
We had really cool gifts like
one of the more popular gifts
that I've always
offered on my campaigns
was the idea of having
your name in the credits,
if you donated $50 or $60.
I never thought this thing
would be as big as it was.
I mean, on 9 Rides, and Last
Fall, we maybe had 100 names.
With Hair Love, we had 1,300
names in our in credits.
And I never would
have anticipated
that many people got
involved, and that was always
the more popular one.
And just being creative
you, depending on what
your project is.
For us, a book made sense.
T-shirts made sense.
Pens made sense, but that
may be different for you
and your project.
So just being very custom and
thinking about what people like
and also, not doing
too many things that
are too expensive because
then the creation of the gifts
and shipping them out take
away from your final money
that you raised to.
So I hope that was helpful.
One thing I want to say
is, from a studio side,
not one penny was
spent in marketing.
So it's so hard to get
people's attention,
just to pay attention
to anything.
So even if you're not
doing a Kickstarter,
let's say and you're doing a
studio movie, studios value
filmmakers that have a
connection to their audience
because that just makes it
that much easier to find
an authentic way
in to an audience.
Thank you so much.
All right.
That does it for our questions.
I want to thank you
all for the questions,
but also, particularly, Matthew
H Cherry, Karen Rupert Toliver.
If we didn't before, we
all have Hair Love now.
We're so happy to be
a part of the family,
if just for this afternoon.
So on behalf of Academy
Gold, I thank you,
and I personally thank you
for this delightful experience
and for the gift of your film
and the projects to come.
So congratulations,
and thank you.